orden de los dígitos 260 y 1 para
obtener el número más grande posible
como yo lo veo para obtener el mayor
número posible debo poner el dígito más
grande en la posición de mayor valor si
es un número de cuatro dígitos
voy a tener cuatro lugares o cuatro
posiciones
1 2 3
en esta posición la que está más hacia
la izquierda es la de mayor valor aquí
van a ir los millares le sigue esta
posición la tercera en dónde van las
centenas las siguientes está donde van
las decenas y finalmente esa posición
totalmente a la derecha donde van las
unidades así que el número que ponga
aquí va a representar a los millares el
que ponga aquí va a representar a las
centenas el que ponga aquí a las decenas
y el que ponga aquí a las unidades
entonces quiero el número más grande
posible tengo que poner en esta posición
que es la que da mayor valor a toda la
cantidad el dígito más grande y el
dígito más grande aquí es el 6 así que
aquí voy a poner el 6 esto va a
representar un 6 mil si pusiera
cualquiera de los otros dígitos en esta
posición la cantidad final no sería la
más grande ahora queremos el siguiente
dígito más grande para la siguiente
posición de más valor
el siguiente dígito es
el 2 así que este 2 va en esta posición
de las centenas representa un 200 igual
si hubiera puesto aquí un 110 tendría
una centena o 0 centenas pero me
interesa tener una cantidad más grande
así que pongo el dígito aquí en esa
posición de más valor siguiendo la misma
lógica cual sigue bueno nos queda el 1 y
la posición que sigue de más valor es
las escenas aquí pongo este 1 y
finalmente mi valor más pequeño es el 0
que lo voy a poner aquí mi cantidad más
grande con estos 4 dígitos es 6210
este es el número más grande con estos
dígitos en cambio si nos hubieran pedido
el número más pequeño lo que tendría que
hacer es poner este cero en la posición
de mayor valor básicamente sería
invertir todos estos números de manera
que la cantidad con menor valor que
podemos armar usando estos dígitos sería
aquí es cero en los millares uno en las
centenas dos en las decenas y finalmente
el más grande de la posición de menos
valor seis en las unidades 126 pero
bueno eso es lo que nos quedaría si nos
hubieran pedido el número más pequeño
pero nos piden el más grande posible y
es este nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo